[Music]
this video will teach you how to manage
and treat high blood sugar please watch
the entire video before treating your
high blood sugar after you eat food that
contains carbohydrates your body breaks
it down into a sugar called glucose your
body makes a hormone called insulin that
helps you either use or store blood
sugar when you have diabetes your body
does not make enough insulin or cannot
use the insulin it makes properly this
can cause you to have too much sugar in
your blood which is a condition called
hyperglycemia hyperglycemia can happen
when you do not take enough insulin or
diabetes medicine take other medicines
that increase blood sugar eat more food
or carbohydrates than you usually do do
not get enough exercise or physical
activity get sick injured or have
surgery have emotional stress such as
family or work problems or have changes
to hormone levels such as during
menstrual periods
[Music]
if you have hyperglycemia or your blood
sugar is too high you may feel very
thirsty and have to urinate a lot you
may also feel very tired and notice your
vision is blurry if you do not treat
hyperglycemia your blood sugar may build
up to a dangerously high level requiring
you to seek immediate emergency care the
first step to understanding how to treat
high blood sugar is knowing your normal
blood sugar target range
if you feel or notice symptoms of
hyperglycemia be sure to check your
blood sugar level right away if your
blood sugar is above your target range
make sure you drink plenty of water or
other sugar-free liquids to stay
hydrated take your insulin or diabetes
medication the way your healthcare
provider says you should
do not take extra medication without
first checking with your health care
provider check your blood sugar every
four hours follow your normal meal plan
and increase your physical activity or
exercise if you can do not exercise if
your blood sugar is above 240 exercise
may make your blood sugar level go even
higher contact your health care provider
if your blood sugar stays above your
target range or you notice the following
symptoms that may need immediate
treatment shortness of breath
breath that smells fruity or your mouth
feels very dry you can help prevent
hyperglycemia by regularly checking your
blood sugar following your normal meal
plan taking your diabetes medication as
prescribed by your doctor
controlling stress and exercising
regularly
[Music]